[Musique]
Kristen Stewart merci beaucoup
de nous recevoir aujourd'hui tout d'abord
félicitation pour ta performance dans le
film Seberg jeune grand amour le film
avais tu déjà entendu parler de Jean Seberg
avant d'avoir le scénario avant de lire
le scénario avant même de se voir proposer le
rôle  avez-vous déjà entendu parler d'elle
?  l'époque où les acteurs étaient plus
performatifs, surtout dans les
films américains, elle était si présente et honnête et un
peu surprenante comme s'il ne
savait jamais vraiment ce qu'elle allait faire
comme si elle se sentait comme un chat ouais alors
mais c'était tout je ne savais pas  à propos de cette
période de sa vie, je n'ai pas
réalisé qu'elle racontait l'histoire forte
qu'elle avait ouais je n'avais pas l'histoire qui
était très ironiquement et avec succès
submergée que les gens ne connaissent pas
Peu de gens pensent à Jean Seberg et
ils pensent à bout de souffle et c'était la
même position dans laquelle j'étais, puis j'ai
lu le scénario pour en savoir plus et j'ai été
vraiment choqué par le genre de
nature tragique de ce qui lui est arrivé et son
implication dans le  Le
mouvement des Black Panthers et le fait qu'elle ait donné de l'
argent à ce moment ouais à ce moment-
là il y avait une énorme guerre
contre les Noirs qui pour être honnête
se produit toujours mais ce ouais elle a
toujours défendu l'égalité et elle
n'était pas comme debout  sur des caisses à savon en
criant à ce sujet, elle faisait juste un don à
qui des groupes d'activistes et des groupes nationalistes noirs dont
l'un est les
Black Panthers oui, évidemment, certaines
personnes remarqueront vraiment des
similitudes entre vous et votre carrière
et un Jean Seberg et sa carrière que
pensez-vous que vous  ont plus en commun avec
Jean Seberg Je pense qu'elle avait cette sorte de
nature impulsive Je pense qu'elle était
idéaliste et naïve parfois
tout ce qu'elle faisait venait d'un  très
honnête et comme un endroit bien intentionné
et elle aimait vraiment les gens c'était une
bonne personne
qu'elle voulait aimer livrer un message
peut-être que cela pourrait être quelqu'un qui en avait
qu'elle voulait être pertinent et non
parce que c'était égoïste de quelque façon
qu'elle  n'était-ce pas parce qu'elle
voulait être importante ouais elle croyait vraiment
en elle elle voulait vraiment être utile
ouais elle avait des idées fortes et elle
voulait représenter ces idées dans la façon dont
elle faisait son travail revenons à votre
carrière tu es sur le point d'être récompensée ici
à Deauville par un prix du talent pour
ta carrière tu n'as que 29 ans
mais tu joues dans des films depuis
vingt ans une heure comment considères-
tu ce que tu as déjà accompli en tant
qu'actrice es-tu fière  de toi es-
tu satisfait de ce que tu as
déjà fait ouais je vais taper je pense que
j'ai fini je pense que je l'ai fait tu sais
satisfait excitant d'accord je plaisante
personne ne pourrait être satisfait et peut-être  plein
d'assez de joie et  edger bien je suis tellement
heureux tu sais que je suis très épanoui j'ai
eu la chance et c'est une
affirmation vraiment profonde j'ai été si complètement
stimulé et épanoui depuis que j'ai
neuf ans
avec l'opportunité de raconter des
histoires  et donc ouais c'est un peu
déconcertant je ne sais pas ce que je ferais
sans ça
mais avez-vous un objectif en tant qu'actrice
peut-être être quelqu'un que vous
n'avez pas encore pu jouer vous
savez inquiet pour un Oscar par exemple
vous  j'ai ce genre d'objectif non Jenni
vraiment pas moi je ne sais pas ce qui
va se passer et c'est comme ça
que j'aime ça je n'ai pas mes objectifs sont expérientiels
comme mes objectifs sont de passer mon temps à me
sentir excité et activé et l'art
est une chose bizarre  ça vous traverse en quelque sorte
c'est comme si vous vous sentiez toujours chanceux que
cela vous soit arrivé oui donc il n'y a vraiment
aucun moyen de planifier cela et je viens d'écrire
un film que j'ai vraiment hâte de réaliser
et c'est une sorte d'impulsion différente
mais  encore un similaire qui évidemment
r  nécessite plus de réflexion et de planification
alors qu'en tant qu'actrice, vous restez juste
fidèle à vos instincts et soyez présente et
honnête et allez-y et
ne perdez pas le contrôle de cela, mais
vous n'en avez pas marre de jouer non pas du
tout j'adore  ça oh non non j'aime vraiment vraiment
ce mec pourrait mourir pour ça ouais
comme tu l'as dit je veux dire je ne veux pas ouais
je ne veux pas mourir oui dis ouais j'ai dit
c'est une image comme ouais c'est un bon moyen
de communiquer  cette idée ouais j'ai lu
que parfois vous aviez choisi de refuser
d'interpréter certains personnages même si vous
saviez qu'ils étaient bons ils étaient bons
juste parce que comme vous l'avez dit vous ne vous
sentiez pas à les jouer ce qui vous fait
accepter un personnage spécifique vous importe
faites dire oui à celui-ci et celui-
ci c'est un peu impossible à décrire
ils sont juste c'est une énorme
responsabilité que
vous ne pouvez pas dire à un cinéaste qui a pris des
années de sa vie pour écrire quelque chose
mettre en place une histoire le temps et l'
effort  qui mène à e  Ce premier jour
de tournage est immense et à moins
que vous ne pensiez pouvoir le faire ou que ce ne soit dans
votre corps d'une manière ou d'une autre physiquement, vous avez
répondu à un personnage,
vous ne pouvez pas très bien prendre le rôle,
c'est comme si c'était une chose irresponsable et imprudente
à faire et je  Je ne sais jamais si je
vais être capable de livrer, mais comme
il y a juste un certain sentiment, ce sentiment de
faim que vous ressentez si vous lisez
quelque chose et que vous y allez, j'ai besoin de mâcher
chacun de ces mots dont j'ai besoin pour mettre
ces chaussures et courir  autour du pâté de maisons
maintenant dans le film un Bouddha souffle à
bout de souffle il y a une scène dans laquelle le
gars qui aime le personnage de Jean Seberg il
lui a demandé tu veux tu ne veux pas
connaître l'avenir et elle a dit oui je
peux donc je peux te demander  de même voulez-vous
savoir ce que vous deviendrez
non je ne pense pas donc j'ai l'impression que
cela gâcherait le processus
pour y arriver c'est aussi une hypothèse
qui me laisse un peu perplexe en ce moment
parce que j'ai besoin de plus de détails
comme tiens bon combien fais  Je sais à
quel moment arrêtez-vous de savoir comme faire
comme euh aussi comme quand est-ce que c'est fini comme
finalement comme à quel
point parlons-nous de la mort comme allons-
nous aimer comment comme ce que
vous avez accompli avant de mourir
comme  non, je veux dire, je pense que si
j'aimais répondre que d'une manière plus ambiguë, je suis
comme noble, je dirais que je n'ai pas
besoin de savoir ce qui s'en vient, je pense que je
pense que lorsque vous abandonnez une sorte de
contrôle et que vous aimez la planification manifeste
comme quand des choses vraiment cool peuvent arriver
et que vous devez en quelque sorte vous soumettre
à l'inconnu, vous savez ouais il y a quelques
années Judy Foster et plus récemment
Olivier Assayas, ils ont prédit que
vous deviendrez certainement un cinéaste,
c'est que ce que vous visez vous
rêvé le plus je ne sais pas je veux dire
je pense que je vais à cent pour cent dans
ce que je fais à l'époque je viens de
finir l'adaptation pour le film
que je vais réaliser et je n'ai pas
aimé  financement ou quelque chose comme  ça mais
je peux je peux vous assurer que je vais faire
ce film l'année prochaine et il aura
tout de moi jouer est une chose bizarre
parce que cela nécessite d'autres personnes je n'ai
pas de personnages que je veux jouer je n'ai
pas je ne serai jamais  capable de planifier cela,
c'est toujours une chose très surprenante quand
une histoire ou un personnage est présenté et que
vous avez ce sentiment compulsif de faim
pour le jouer Je ne sais pas combien de temps cela
va durer oui mais je l'ai depuis que je
suis un peu  gamin et ce n'est jamais
parti donc ce serait un peu choquant si
tout d'un coup je m'en
fichais du je ne fais pas une énorme distinction
entre jouer et diriger c'est un
travail complètement différent mais l'impulsion
est toujours la même  eh bien il est peut-être trop
tôt maintenant pour répondre à cette question
ouais tu sais que ce serait ma dernière
question c'est drôle tu as un
lien spécial une relation spéciale avec des
amis et j'ai entendu dire que tu
aimes aussi cuisiner y a-t-il un repas français
que tu fais et tu vas adorer
oh mon dieu je  Je ne sais pas, laissez-moi voir, laissez-
moi voir, je pense qu'il y a probablement
des influences françaises et certaines des
choses que je veux dire, je ne sais pas si je fais un
plat particulièrement français, mais je veux dire que j'ai
beaucoup appris en mangeant ici.  quelque chose
comme la façon de vous goûter le vin peut-être
ouais
vraiment ouais je suis ouais le Bordeaux
et Air France est vraiment tueur permettez-moi de
dire tout le monde je le sais comme
ma poche ils vous aideraient
à savoir mais je pense  si vous aimez la nourriture
ouais comme si vous l'appréciiez vraiment, vous savez
comment le faire comme ça et donc manger
ici a certainement été l'une
des meilleures expériences que j'ai eues avec
merci beaucoup pour son interview
merci beaucoup pour pour  tes paroles comme pour
nous
[Musique]